الرئيس الصينيه شيجن بينج اكد انه يجب على
دول العالم التصدي بحزم لمحاولات التسييس
واستخدام الغذائي سلاحا والطاقه كذلك
ان من الضروري رفع العقوبات الاحاديه
الجانب ورفع القيود المفروضه على التعاون
العلميه ضياء
لمساعده الدول الناميه في حل المشاكل في
مجال الغذائي وامن الطاقه
والتخزين وتمويل والمساعده الفنيه
والترسيم الهيدروجين سيؤدي الى تقويض
التقدم العالمي
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصيني وان اي معارضه
بلاده استبعاد روسيا من دول العشرين
الكبار ومن المنصات الدوليه الاخرى
على هامش القمه ان على روسيا والصين
متابعه النقاش المباشر كقوتين عظمتين
سعيد بمشاركتكم في قمه العشرين وتمثيل
روسيا فيها ندعم دور روسيا الفاعل في اطار
قمه العشرين وفي اطار المنصات الدوليه
الاخرى ونعتبر انه لا يحق لاحد سالب روسيا
حقها في المشاركه بالمنصات الدوليه متعدده
الاطراف
لام
ماذا بعد
نعم هذه القمه حقيقه هي تعنى بدايه في
مناطق في قضايا هناك توافق عليها كالامن
الغذائي امن الطاقه قضايا انسانيه وكذلك
قضيه تنسيق الجهود من اجل مواجهه ايه او
مستقبليه ولكن هناك قضايا لا يوجد فيها
اتفاق وذلك بسبب وجود اطراف هي خصوم
سياسيه في هذا الوقت الحالي والحديث هنا
طبعا عن الولايات المتحده وروسيا العطوين
في مجموعه ال 20 هذه هذا الوضع حقيقه
الخصومه بين البلدين حتى الان ادت الى عدم
صدور بيان ختام لقمه مجموعات ال 20 رغم
اندونيسيا الدوله
الترتيب لهذه القمه
لدول مجموعه العشرين اذا لا يوجد بيان
ختامي وربما نقاط الخلاف بحسب ما ذكره
مسؤول رفيع في البيت الابيض هي تتمحور حول
الصياغه الولايات المتحده وهكذا الاتحاد
الاوروبي بحسب ما اكدت لنا بالامس رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بوندور لاين يريدون لي
البيان ختامي ان يتضمن جمله
تمدد بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا مما
قاله لنا مسؤول رفيع في البيت الابيض حتى
اليوم بانه حتى صباح اليوم لم يكن هناك
اتفاق على وجود هذه العباره ضمن البيانات
ولذلك تحاول الولايات المتحده الدول
الغربيه بان همم تضيف عباره بعض او معظم
الدول مجموعه ال 20 تدين الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وهذه العباره تعرقل حتى
اللحظه صدور البيان الختام لقمه العشرين
هذه القمه حقيقه وبالحديث عن القضايا التي
تعنى بها ايضا كان فيها قبل قليل اجتماع
انتهى قمه لم يكن يخططا مها لها بين
الرئيسين الامريكي والتركي همم البيت
الابيض اصدر قبل لحظات قليله فقط وانا
بانتظار ان اطل عليكم مريم اصدر بيانا
بشان هذا اللقاء الذي انتهى قبل قليل
البيت الابيض شكر وعربه الرئيس خلال
اللقاء عن تقديره لجهود الرئيس اردوغان في
تجديد مبادره همم حبوب البحر الاسود طبعا
هذه المبادره وهي ضروريه جدا وحاسمه بحسب
البيت الابيض في ما يتعلق بالامن الغذائي
للعالم وكذلك ناقش الرئيسان استمرار تنسيق
الوثيق بشان قضايا حلف الناتو ثمنا البيان
جهود همم دوله تركيا ضمن حلف الناتو كذلك
الرئيس قدم تعازيه للرئيس اردوغان اا على
ماذا بحسب وصف البيت الابيض العنف الذي
شاهدته تركيا مؤخرا وطبعا ذلك همم المقصود
به الهجوم الانتحاري في ميدان تقسيم في
تركيا
اذا قضايا كثيره همم هنا في هذه القمه
الجلسه الثانيه انتهت قبل قليل من المفترض
ان يكون الرئيس الان في لقاء مع رئيس
الوزراء الجزيره